والله قمه
الخير قمه التنميه قمه الارتقاء هذه قمه
البحرين كثير من الملفات
اللي يترقبها المواطن الخليجي فيها الكثير
من التفاؤل والاسباب
بان منظومه مجلس التعاون خلال السنوات
اللي
فاتت وصلت الى مراحل جدا متقدمه من
التنسيق والتعاون اذا شفت العسكري اعتقد
درع الجزيره كان احدى نتاج هذه
المنظومه
التمرين الامني الاخير
اللي كان في
البحرين اصبح عندنا جهاز شرطه
موحد الهيئه الاقتصاديه التنمويه اللي
تراسها صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن
سلمان ولي العهد
السعودي كلها هذه مؤشرات بان هذه قمه خير
قوات درع الجزيره موجوده ومستمره وفي
مرحله تطوير مستمر ما توقفت طوال السنوات
اللي
مضت لذلك احنا ما يهدد اي دوله خليجيه هو
يهدد الخليج العربي باكمله احنا اليوم في
دول الخليج نعتبر كدول متحده سادس اقتصاد
في
العالم لذلك دول الخليج لها ثقلها
الاقتصادي اللي يحتم عليها التنسيق دائم
حفاظا على الكثير من المكتسبات الاقتصاديه
والمحافظه عليها وتطويرها وايجاد
بدائل لما يخدم شعوب هذه المنطقه زياره
خادم الحرمين الشريفين هي في اطار جوله
يقوم بها خادم الحرمين الشريفين حفظه الله
ورعاه لدول مجلس التعاون بداها بدوله
الامارات العربيه المتحده واليوم كان في
قطر وان شاء الله بكره راح يكون في
البحرين هذه الزياره يترقبها الشعب
البحريني بكثير من الفرح
والترحيب وجود رئيسه الوزراه البريطانيه
في البحرين
ومؤشر اهميه هذه المنطقه ووجودها في قمه
مجلس التعاون وبعدين العلاقه المتميزه
اللي تربط البحرين بريطانيا لاكثر من 200
عام